Stacy Abrams was interviewed by Drew
Barrymore who has a I suppose a talk
show or something like that and she
recounted this story
um of uh that's probably entirely
invented but still funny and ironic in
its own right so the story about kind of
her origin story
about
um being you know
dumped and dissed by a man and how that
fueled her moving forward uh listen to
this
so when I was in college I fell in love
with a boy who was mean to me
um oh God yeah yeah you know what we've
all done that yeah well he broke up with
me and he said that I was too ambitious
and wanted too many things and I would
end up alone and lonely and so I got
really mad and then I was like fine I'm
gonna figure out all the things I'm
going to do to make him Rue the day that
he was mean to me and so I this was now
I'm old I'm 49. so I'm going to be 48
we're right next to each other so you'll
appreciate this this was before Excel
this is when it was Lotus one two three
right okay you had to go to the computer
lab because owning a computer meant that
you could buy the world right I went to
the computer lab at Spelman and I did a
spreadsheet and I laid out all the
things I was going to accomplish in all
the ways I was going to just be
fantastic and magnificent and I don't
know if he's ever going to see it but
I'm I'm doing okay I'm I'm doing okay
almost right there well again I don't
know where to begin with this first of
all look how into it Drew Barrymore is
she is she is just she's wrapped up in
this almost certainly made up story
that by the way if it's true I'm doing
Stacey Abrams a favor here I'm cutting
her some slack I'm gonna give her the
benefit of the doubt that she's just
making that up to give herself an
interesting story to tell it's not all
that interesting
and even making it up she can't she's
like I fell in love with a boy who was
uh mean to me
Drew Barrymore oh my God mean to you oh
no have you ever read the fine print
that appears when you start browsing an
incognito mode it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school or your internet
service provider to actually stop people
from monitoring your online activity you
need to do what I do and use expressvpn
think about all the times you've used
Wi-Fi at a coffee shop a hotel or even a
friend's house without expressvpn every
site you visit can be logged by the
Admin of that Network that's still true
even when you're in incognito mode
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
that your private online activity stays
private expressvpn works on all your
devices and it's really easy to use the
app just has one button you tap it to
connect and your browsing activity is
secure it's as simple as that stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com mattwall show use my Link
at expressvpn.com Matt walshow to get
three extra months free that's exp
resvpn.com Matt Walsh show today
but if the story is true this is
psychotic pathetic Behavior so you you
set up a spreadsheet that you still
apparently refer to
because there was one kid
like two decades ago he didn't want to
go out with you
I mean there were a lot more than
there's a lot more than one person who
want to go out with you but it's like
this one person
and so and so you have been driven this
is what the feminists they think that
this is inspiring
so they may make up a story in which she
is driven by Spite because there was one
kid who didn't want to go out with her
did he have to go out with you
like was he not allowed to say no
no means no Stacey Abrams
but the greatest thing of all is that
apparently this guy said that you're
going to be lonely and alone
and and he was right because that's
exactly what happened usually when you
tell a story like this
I I tried I fell in love with this
person and they said that I was going to
be lonely and alone that's when you
follow up by saying and I showed him I'm
happily married I have four kids um but
that's not the case for her she's not
married she's childless
and she is most famous for losing
elections one that's all she's done
childless alone and her whole career has
just been losing things
and so I I that guy if he exists
not only right but he uh we could say we
really he dodged a bullet too so well
done to that young man
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]